in honor of Leonardo DiCaprio's win my
outfit of the day is the bear from
revenant you wear the title of this
video I think let's review some of the
Oscars red carpet fashion this is my
badge of certification this should tell
you all the reasons why I shouldn't be
doing this brie Larson you and I have so
much in common
not like talent like you have talent our
names are associated with things that we
are not your name is brie but you're not
cheese my name is Grace and I'm not
amazing take that me brie you look like
a girl in a dress like you're going to
an ice dancer prom very Michelle Kwan
cute Jennifer Lawrence damn girl you got
a babyface and a lady body whoa this is
interesting like a sexy feather duster
it's like you took all the nipple
tassels and just put them around your
waist we need to accentuate the nipples
nipples are so 2050s
let's focus on the waist what waist not
- we'll never be friends but your hair
looks really pretty and healthy Kate
Winslet
I'm very enticed I don't think Jack
could let go if he tried because I think
you're covered in duct tape you look
like a very high-class oil spill there's
a lot of political commentary at the
awards last night and this might be
commentary on the BP oil spill Kate
always looks great I'm Kate Winslet
trash and it looks like she is too kind
of looks like a garbage bag but like a
really talented expensive garbage bag
it's cute
Charlize Theron we get it you're
beautiful and you wear clothing so well
like what how why why Amy Poehler I
appreciate this
Lady Gaga I like this because it's like
hey look I'm wearing a dress like sneaky
pants I hope that that is the name of
her new album you kind of look like a
wishbone I like a sexy sexy wishbone
like Oh Hollywood wishbone I wish we
would be friends
Kerry Washington very gladiator meets
Kleenex two things that I like a
vulnerable warrior
that's a nice perfume
name or that's a nice line of tampons
named Kerry Washington you have inspired
me
Kate Blanchet oh you two are going to
the ice dancer prom Rooney Mara
she's smiling I don't care what you're
wearing I'm so distracted by the fact
that you might be exuding a positive
emotion you don't always feel pain but
maybe the open hole in the front of the
dress is some little symbolism cute
Heidi Klum hey I feel like so many
people in Heidi's life have told her you
could wear anything and make it look
great and she's like oh really
watch this this is cute you look like a
My Little Pony tail just the tail what
we goldberg having a great time she
looks great big fam Tina Fey shoot she
look great how why Jared Leto Wow look
like a street magician and I think you
might be one because you just melted my
brain for a second Oh buddy
those shoes have snakes on them and the
flower cool why not more things this
outfit needs more things cool job your
eyes burn holes in my soul that's cool
what an accessory rachel mcadams someone
sat down uh oh wow beautiful color but
someone sat down we all know that women
are never supposed to sit down and
dresses how dare you be a human for Elle
you're cool and your wife looks like so
over the fact that you're cool I like
that as a duo you and your wife are
accentuated parts of the body that are
often overlooked ankles in this area
give it to us
2016 we deserve it well there you go
there is my 2016 Oscars red carpet
fashion review I hope that you enjoyed
this let me know who you thought look
great and otherwise and don't forget to
scribe ha ha here's a button so easy for
you to do just do it and I will see you
you know yeah I'm around I don't know
Jacob Tremblay ah
who taught you to post like an adult
with your hands in your pockets like
that children never put their hands in
their pockets kids don't even know about
pockets until they're like teenagers cuz
that's where they hide the condom I
should not say the word condom
and anything in reference to you child
after you just look too self-assured and
a young age good for you but also like
maybe I go outside and a rolling dirt
for a little bit you can